We have a whole bunch of economic news, we
have GDP numbers.
We also have new unemployment numbers.
Unemployment numbers probably will not talk
about today, probably tomorrow.
But I do want to talk about GDP.
So we are in the middle of a pandemic.
We anticipated that Q1 GDP numbers, quote,
Q1, of course, January, February, March would
not be great.
Q2, in which we are right now, we expect to
be really bad.
And then there's certainly a question mark
around Q3 and the idea that Q4 numbers will
be dramatically recovered.
So what does the first quarter look like?
Why do we care about GDP?
Well, when we're trying to figure out the
economic impact of the Corona virus, we look
at the stock market, even though it doesn't
really tell us that much.
And we've talked about why before we look
at unemployment, how many people are working,
how many people are losing their jobs.
We look at wages and we've also been waiting
on GDP.
Q1 GDP was down 4.8 percent.
This is the largest drop since late 2008 in
the throes of the Great Recession.
This is the first GDP decline at all in six
years.
And it's not surprising we were expecting
this to understand these numbers.
First, it helps to know what GDP is.
GDP is the gross domestic product.
That's the total value of goods produced and
services provided off you.
If you have two businesses, a factory and
a hair salon, for lack of a better term, for
lack of a better example, the factory produces
one hundred dollars worth of goods.
The hair salon provides one hundred dollars
worth of haircuts.
That's two hundred dollars in total product
as this GDP is measured.
Of course, there are many other elements that
go into it.
It went down in the first quarter because
we had January and February, which were reasonably
normal months as far as the economy's concerned.
And then in March, stay at home orders started
because of Corona virus.
Businesses shut down, fewer things were sold,
fewer people were working, fewer services
were provided in the second quarter, which
is April, May, June, we are about a third
of the way through Q2.
There's the idea that GDP could be down as
much as 20 percent.
Some people are even throwing around the number
30 percent, which is devastating.
These are we've actually become numb.
Today we learned another 3.8, 3.6, something
like that.
Million people filed for unemployment last
week.
That's way down from a few weeks ago.
But it is an insane number, historically speaking,
and we've become numb to these numbers of
absolute economic devastation.
So now let's go beyond the headlines and really
dig into some of the data that made up the
GDP decline of 4.8 percent, because that may
not be what you expected.
It's very interesting.
So first of all, we can separate personal
consumption into goods and services, as I
mentioned before.
Goods and services combine to make up GDP.
Goods were actually almost unchanged.
Goods as part of Q1 GDP were only down a tiny
bit.
Now, maybe this is intuitive.
Maybe it's not durable.
Goods like cars and furnishings were certainly
down.
There's not a lot of car sales going on.
Many dealerships are closed.
Furnishings.
People aren't really going out and buying
too much furniture right now.
But nondurable goods were actually up about
1 percent.
So that includes, of course, food and beverages
that are consumed off premises, meaning grocery
stores.
That makes sense.
Goods almost unchanged overall in total services,
of course, were down.
Household spending on services was down pretty
significantly, about 6 percent.
But there was also a major decrease in health
care spending.
And this is something that really tells us
a lot about how our economy is organized and
not particularly for the better.
So you might imagine wait to think we've got
a pandemic.
Everything that's going on right now is because
of a medical situation that people need treatment
for.
People are filling hospitals for.
How is it that with a million, almost 1.1
million confirmed cases of coronavirus in
the United States.
Health care spending was down during Q1.
And the answer is that routine health care
is almost completely shut down.
Everything from dermatology visits for a skin
rash to elective and non-emergency surgery.
It's all but canceled.
This also reminds us that the main point of
our health care system is to make money.
The economy is hugely reliant on revenue from
health care, and that's not good when in my
view, the main goal of health care should
be to keep people and to make people healthy,
not to make money.
This is a structural analysis that can be
done.
When you're trying to think about how an industry
functions, if we ask how do cable news channel,
what is the main purpose of cable news channels?
Is it to inform people as much as possible?
No, it's to make money.
Once you understand the primary purpose of
an industry, you understand why they make
the editorial decisions that they make, et
cetera, so on and so forth.
If you look at the health care industry in
the United States, when you realize, well,
it's primarily organized to be a profit center,
it's primarily organized to make money.
It tells you a lot about why it fails in the
areas in which it fails.
And what we are seeing during a medical pandemic,
during a viral pandemic, which is a medical
event, we are seeing one of the largest reductions
in GDP came from the health care industry
because so much of that industry, of course,
you've got emergency rooms which are very
full.
You have ICU use, you have hospital beds.
But when you're looking at everything from,
you know, orthopedic, you need to have your
knee scope to arthroscopic surgery on your
knee, for example.
You're putting that off.
Orthopedic surgeries are very, very profitable.
You get the idea.
So when we look at those numbers, a large
portion of the decline in GDP in Q1 came from
within the healthcare industry.
So 4.8 percent decline in Q1.
If we have a full quarter of locked.
April, May, June, the numbers could be absolutely
devastating.
Now, some states are starting to open probably
too soon.
Remember, though.
Trump can't open the country.
Trump can't open states, governors can't even
really do it.
They can allow it.
But even if businesses start having employees
standing there waiting for you to come in.
If people don't go in, the numbers are not
going to be dramatically better.
My sense right now is May is going to be not
good, but it will probably be better than
April.
Hopefully June can be salvaged to some degree.
And I mean that both economically, psychologically,
socially, culturally, everything.
But we just don't know.
We have to go where the data takes us.
And right now, we are still having huge death
numbers.
We I think yesterday we found another 24000
new cases.
So we've been in a plateau that's lasted about
a full months.
And I don't believe at the at the national
level, we are clearly on the other side of
it.
States like New York are nationally.
The numbers are still very, very high.